bonjour françois poulets bâtisse merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors il
ya beaucoup de choses à l'ordre du jour
de ce sommet européen aujourd'hui et
demain tout d'abord le déblocage du plan
de relance de 750 milliards d'euros
il y à sauver tous polonais apparemment
en bonne voie de déblocage il y aurait
eu un accord avec l'allemagne
en quoi consiste-t-il selon vous cet
accord alors cet accord consiste
essentiellement la possibilité
finalement de soumettre un accord qui
lie
l'obtention de ce plan de relance à la
joue au changement démocratique dans ces
deux pays c'est à dire la hongrie et la
pologne est il sage consiste simplement
à soumettre cette possibilité à la cour
de justice de luxembourg et donc de voir
si effectivement cette conditionnalité
est compatible avec les accords
européens et donc c'est une manière pour
l'union européenne de dire voilà on fait
un petit peu la différence entre
l'accord lui même qui doit pas avoir de
conditionnalité immédiate
et puis effectivement le souci de
maintenir quand même une pression pour
que ces deux pays respecte un peu plus
les valeurs de l'union en sens à cet
accord c'est important parce que
finalement tout était bloqué 750
milliards du plan de relance mais aussi
les 1000 milliards du budget pluriannuel
de l'union
tout cela était bloquée à cause de cette
opposition dé ces deux états qui ont
finalement accepté de revenir à une
certaine sagesse et je pense compte que
sur ce plan contours à un accord l
auriez aussi sur la table la question
des sanctions qui pourraient être
imposées à la turquie là aussi de quelle
nature concédés sanctions qui sont plus
des sanctions et persona puisqu'il
s'agit pas de trop pénaliser les
rapports économiques qui sont déjà
pénalisés entre l'union européenne et la
turquie
et donc c'est plus sur ce plan là que
les sanctions pourraient pour aller mais
vous l'avez entendu il ya un instant le
président erdogan ne sont pas trop
d'illusions sur les conséquences que
pourrait avoir de telles sanctions
il ya aussi le fait qu'il ya encore des
oppositions au sein de l'union
européenne sur l'intensité de ces
sanctions certains pays soit de ne pas
aller trop loin
bien là dessus je pense qu'il y aura un
accord mais ça sera un accord a minima
ne pas aller trop loin pour pour quelle
raison parce qu'on a besoin de la
turquie notamment pour sur la question
de l'immigration parce qu'on ne veut
bien sûr besoin de la turquie pour
respecter les accords d'immigration pour
pas qu'ils aient de surenchère pourquoi
pas qu'on assiste de nouveau à une anna
flux d'immigrés envoyé par la turquie
vers les frontières européennes
cela ait eu serait extrêmement
dommageable bien sûr il s'agit d'éviter
cela mais je pense que il y aura un
accord mais cet accord effectivement
sera un accord a minima je pense autre
question que l'on que l'on se pose pour
ce sommet européen c'est la question du
brésil est ce qu'on va enfin pouvoir
trouver un accord d'ici à dimanche on
dit ursula von der leyen et et boris
johnson moi j'étais quand même
relativement inquiet sur l'issue du
repas d'hier soir il ya trois éléments
qui m'inquiète particulièrement sur la
possibilité d'un accord d'ici dimanche
d'une part sur le fait qu'il n'y ait pas
eu de communiqué commun il s'agit là
communiqué de l'union européenne de
ursula von der leyen qui dit en
substance
nos positions sont encore très éloignées
et qui dit dans le même temps il faudra
qu'une décision dit soit prise dimanche
dont on ne voit pas très bien de quelle
décision il faut s agir sinon sinon eu
un constat simplement de désaccord un
constat de désaccord qui ouvrirait à la
voix sur 1 1 d'accord sur anodine
j'en veux pour preuve que certains
accords qui était encore petit planète
ont été acquis ces derniers jours il y à
avant-hier pas plus tard notamment celui
sur l'irlande du nord où finalement les
britanniques ont accepté le principe
d'un retrait de leur fameuse loi qui
contredisaient l'accord de retrait et
qui ont accepté lui certaine manière que
l'on qu'on trouve un accord pour que
l'irlande du nord et la république
d'irlande ne subissent pas la
réintroduction d'une frontière et c'est
important parce que cet accord
finalement serait acquis quelle que soit
l'issue de la négociation il serait
acquis même si il y à un accord ce qui
prouverait finalement que des deux côtés
côté britannique comme côté européen on
admet l'idée tout à fait plausible que
ici la semaine prochaine il n'y a pas
d'accord du tout sûr sûr sûr sûr ce deal
entre l'union européenne et sur ce
retrait de l'ue de la grande bretagne de
l'union européenne s'il n'y a pas
d'accord ça veut dire que les eaux
territoriales britanniques reviendrait
au britannique et donc que les pêcheurs
français ne pourraient plus y pêcher
voilà donc on cherche à éviter ça il y a
eu quand même des mouvements sur cette
question de la pêche faut pas dire que
rien s'est passé même la france qui est
un peu accusé par les britanniques
d'avoir une position extrêmement dur
même la france a admis le principe que
finalement les britanniques pouvaient
très bien revendiquer une reprise de
contrôle sur ces zones à condition que
cela ne chamboule pas complètement les
équilibres en matière de pêche notamment
et les avenirs de l'industrie de la
pêche des deux côtés dont il s'agit par
exemple pour la france d'admettre qu'ils
poulies pourrait-il y avoir une
dégressivité une progressivité dans le
rétablissement d'une certaine à certains
contrôles des eaux britanniques par le
royaume uni mais cela doit se faire dans
le temps et cela doit être négocié et
certainement pas finalement de remettre
en cause la totalité de l'accès aux eaux
britanniques
donc sur ce plan là il est possible que
même des pays comme la france qui sont
considérés comme extrêmement dur sur ce
plan finalement évolué et puis je crois
qu'il faut dire aussi une chose c'est
que si la france apparaît très dur à
côté et de l'autre côté l'allemagne
apparaît plus ouverte à un compromis
recherchant davantage un compromis il
faut pas oublier qu'en toutes
circonstances la france et l'allemagne
tous les jours tous les jours se
concertent pour finalement avoir sur ce
dossier une position commune qui est la
seule condition pour maintenir un
minimum d'unité entre les 27
merci beaucoup françois poulet mathis
pour votre analyse